the taliban are now blocking afghans
from getting to kabul's airport and they
say it is due to security concerns and
because the country needs those people
to stay and help rebuild the first stop
for thousands of afghan refugees is
ramstein air base that's near frankfurt
germany and holly williams is there
where she spoke to some of those
refugees getting out and she joins us
now holly good morning
the afghan evacuees arrive here with
just one small bag of possessions and
inside they carry the anxiety of an
uncertain future and the heartbreak of
losing their country to islamic
extremists
in central germany an afghan village has
sprung up almost overnight
at this giant u.s military air base
service members are doing their best to
calm
[Applause]
and entertain thousands of evacuees
adina gafori told us she worked for an
american organization in kabul and
feared the taliban would kill her but
she had to leave her parents behind i
don't know
am i able to see them again or not am i
able to talk with them or no am i able
to go in a safe place or no
we don't know anything
this is just a way station for the
afghan evacuees they'll stay here a few
days before flying elsewhere very likely
the u.s to start a new life there's one
thing though they all have in common
they may never see their homeland again
it's sad lieutenant colonel simon
ritchie is an air force doctor from
minneapolis who's helping the evacuation
effort their entire life possessions
might be in a plastic shopping bag
it certainly helps to put things in
perspective and what it means to
have good fortune of being born in a
country like america
safari worked as an interpreter for u.s
special forces what would the taliban
have done to you
they were going to kill me right away he
told us his family owe their lives to a
green beret who became a friend
his name is greg adam he's back in the
united states he helped us a lot major
greg adams is now a civilian from his
home in seattle he remotely guided
rakmat and other afghan interpreters
through the chaos at kabul's airport
using text messages i know how much how
many risks they've taken for for us
while while serving overseas and i
really want to see through our moral
obligation my personal obligation but
also our country's obligation adams
risked his life to fight the taliban and
is critical of america's hasty and
disordered withdrawal from afghanistan i
don't necessarily question the decision
to leave i think we could have done
a lot better job of of planning for this
in getting people out
safari told us his ambitions now are to
find work and live peacefully he hopes
in sacramento greg adams says he's still
working to evacuate around 20 more
afghans before august 31st
it's quite a story with major greg adams
thank you very much holly williams
reporting from ramstein air base she's
in germany